hi everyone my name's Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen
I watched Kiki's Delivery Service I made
this headband as an old flannel I was
getting rid of so I'm pretty excited
pretty ready to go in the little
description box of Kiki's Delivery
Service it says she's a witch I didn't
know she was a witch such so I changed
my whole look for today I just tweeted
out giving those predictions for Kiki's
Delivery Service heart emoji tornado
emoji heart emoji let's get started you
haven't seen those perfect timing Ike
obviously I loved it everyone knows I
was gonna love it and I loved it there's
talking cat named Gigi I just wanted to
meet you
and everyone said that I I've been
lacking on hair flips recently so there
you go that's gonna be a bitch to edit
the first thing I wrote down is Gigi's
yes any time there's a talking cat in a
film I'm going to love it obviously guys
obviously Doug come on Elsa like one of
the first lines young people are all the
same they all want to do something
different I love that it's true
let's jiggle my teeth I feel like what's
your name Miranda sings I adore this
animation style a lot at first I wrote
down it was simple but that's not the
case at all I think it's just a lack of
black lives why my mind immediately went
simple it's like I don't know it's
really like muted so she's leaving to go
on her journey at 13 years old and I've
got a couple questions about that that
would come up later this whole thing
like just from the get-go reminds me a
lot of spirited away I realize it's the
same people licking it so obviously it's
like anime right I feel like and I don't
have the authority to say that because
I've not seen any animation I'd like to
watch an anime for this series and I
just don't know which one would work
best if you have suggestions for like
doable ones I need to like watch
something that's going to be easy for me
to get into as a movie - I know I want
to watch Cowboy Bebop
but I don't think I want to do that
whole serious for one episode of Tamra
so soon so she's in her new city gonna
start her new studies and this boy saved
her from getting written up from a cop
and then she sat with him and then he
falls in love with her the tale is all
the time so she leads him she doesn't
know anyone in this city and she has
nowhere to stay and I have so many
questions about this where do her
studies take place what it is she going
to a specific school or is she just like
13 time to get out of the house and go
work what I just do not understand the
whole studies aspect of this story why
does she have to go away for the studies
where she studying did her parents not
give her any advice at all for what to
do when she gets into why is she gonna
live in a big city I don't understand
any of this so you see a baker and one
of the bakers customers had dropped a
pacifier and so Kiki goes and delivers
it and comes back in the Baker's like oh
that was so nice you can stay with us
and it resolves itself very nicely for
Kiki Wow she gets like put into this
upper attic in the Baker's house which
is honestly a dope addict I would fix up
that attic so well it's so cute and at
13 she's really doing well for herself
like honestly
well done Kiki you're damn adult I wrote
ggc's the neighbors lady cat and finds
her attractive but I also think today
Gigi likes the Baker's husband too cuz
Gigi like flirts with him so Gigi just
knows everyone and I loved Eugene so the
delivery service is born and I guess
this is what her study I guess each
which chooses what their their thing is
going to be and then then they just do
it in the real world I guess that's what
it is kind of a little weird kind of a
little muddy there with explanation but
okay taking her first delivery and I am
so sorry but the wild geese getting
blown about was hilarious
that's what ISIL did you same
same smoothie is kind of more like a
series of short stories because it feels
more like a show like set up versus a
movie set up and while I really enjoyed
it it just was like a bunch of short
little stories there wasn't like a fool
or the fool art for sure but less so
then I think most movies I see these you
meet suggest the job who I also think GG
is in love with so another person to add
to the list
Fuji loves so Kiki gets the cat toy and
Eagle crow forest makes friends with the
crow painter and that's kind of the end
of that chapter I've recognized a couple
of the voices in this I'm going to look
up the voice echoes Wow phil heartman
Kirsten Dunst Debbie Reynolds this so
far is it's very very cute and I love
that she's just like this little helper
which that is so kind and helpful she's
less whiny than just hero and spirited
away I really love Kiki as a character
but it's a little it's like mystical
then even though she's a witch you can
fly in a room and talking at it so it's
less mystical too spirited away and I
kind of missed that aspect to it I know
it's a different movie but I did I
really loved like the mystical and the
weird creatures of spirited away the
next little mini story is Kiki helps
these two old ladies who live together
who are so sweet they make a fish pie
Kiki delivers it to her granddaughter
and the granddaughter doesn't like the
fish pie and she's like a super Brad
about it she just bought this greatest
day with these women and like helps them
around the house and then they were so
kind to her and then it's like raining
and she gets there late and the girl
isn't even appreciative of it and then
she misses her party and she gets super
sick and sad it's pretty sad
then she gets better and the guy who
likes her I don't know it looks like
Where's Waldo
junior not soon does like bikes that
he's trying to make flies got a
propeller it's really cute they ride it
together she gets kind of socially
awkward and other people come around and
she just kind of like goes away she's
like I don't feel like an insider I feel
like an outsider I'm like girl you're 13
the food doesn't feel that way at 13
oh no Gigi can't speak anymore this is
devastating no she can't fly she's
losing her powers girl take some insulin
do so
honestly I just devastated it she can't
talk to Gigi anymore it's our only
friends let me know now I can't talk to
my cat either oh I I never could all
right I wrote it's very sad that this 13
year old is so lonely and feel so
powerless
I felt very similarly at 13 again
perfect I mean great maybe that's why
she goes at 13 for her witch's journey
alright maybe okay
forest ranger lets her stay with her in
de forest forest major is my favorite
character Ursula I think her name is a
couple of her lines that I love her
must have been blinded by two gorgeous
women and then a guy says she looks like
a boy she's like what boy has these like
mr. Celeste yes girl she just lives in
the forest and paints and hangs out with
animals that's what I want my aesthetic
to be I want to be heard but then her
man friend sir strikes a lot gets in
trouble and she goes to save him and
through the power of forest magic and
believing in yourself and a new broom
and saving her friend she's able to fly
again she hits the powers back that's
really sweet and then Gigi could talk to
her again
Gigi with a bunch of hearts next to it
and it was really cute and so sweet and
I want to cosplay these three of the
characters like I said I think I enjoy
the mystical aspects of spirited away a
little bit more I enjoy Kiki as a
character more than I did she hero okay
I am going to read some predictions that
you guys sent me hopefully on Twitter
the end of the NZ hocus-pocus review is
going to be a lot funnier to you it's
not what you expected actually this is
what I expected this I think wow maybe I
expected it to be a little bit more
mystical just because I speared it away
you
half a point I predict that you think
that the movie will deliver ah oh I hate
that I liked that you'll love the cat
and have an urge to buy a big red bow
and you know me so well if you're
watching the dubbed version Disney
distributed then Phil Hartman yeah Phil
Hartman and yeah that's what I'm glad I
watched the dubbed Disney version you'll
love it I hope and you'll ask Ike if he
can talk hi
wait just can you just keep can you use
your words please can you talk to me for
a second like no respect you'll love it
be sad flush angry at the little girls a
birthday party and feel a sense of
connectivity to the movie as a whole I
did love it
and I do hate that little girl the
birthday party your grandma loved you I
got to rewatch it now you know some
movie just need them re-watch ability
like you got to rewatch it once just
like really really get it I think this
is one of those you're gonna love Gigi
yeah that's where I'll add that I
apparently can be bought very easily
with a talking cat also I'm not sure
what I'll do next week I might put up a
poll on my Twitter to ask about it I
will come up with something great and
outrageous that I haven't seen at the
beginning of this series I was like
whatever people haven't seen things like
it's not that big of a deal but now that
I've been doing it for such a long time
you know we're going on a year here
weekly cameras ever seen and there's no
end in sight and it's pretty ridiculous
I do understand the comment but since I
totally do I'm gonna keep making thanks
for watching thanks so much and I've got
a delivery to make so
she's gonna oh just I don't think I can
fly with icon unlight really so heavy
yeah okay good call buddy one score
separately bye
[Music]
[Applause]